Image warping
Now we’re going to look at a very general
technique called image warping.
Image warping can be used to perform a large
number of operations on an image and we’re
going to consider some very simple examples
first. But they can all be combined together
to allow for quite complex image transformations.
We did touch on image warping in the last
lecture when we were discussing homographies
and perspective rectification. Let’s consider
first the case of image scaling.
Here we have an input image of the Mona Lisa
and I want to shrink her by a factor of perhaps
a half in each direction. So if the output
image is the same size as the input image
then the shrunken Mona Lisa sits up in the
top left-hand corner. You’ll note here that
there are a large number of pixels in the
output image which are colored red. That’s
because for these pixels we don’t have any
idea what their value should be. We’ve scaled
the Mona Lisa to a quarter of her previous
size but we’ve placed her in an output image
the same size as the input so there are a
whole lot of pixels whose value we are unable
to estimate.
This is a topic we’ll come back to at the
end of this section.
Now I want to combine scaling and shifting.
So we take our original input image and we’re
going to shrink her. We’re going to put
her into the middle of the output image so
she’s been reduced in size and then offset
so that the top left corner of the Mona Lisa
picture is not in the top left corner of the
output image.
I can consider rotation. In order to rotate
the image, I first need to decide the point
about which I will rotate. So we’ll rotate
about a point here just underneath her chin
and we will rotate by something like 45 degrees.
When we place this rotated image into a frame
which is the same size as the input image,
we see a couple of interesting things. We
see firstly that there are some corners of
the output image which is still colored red.
That’s where there are no valid pixels.
We also see that the corners of the Mona Lisa
which stick outside the image are going to
have to be chopped off. So by rotating the
Mona Lisa, we lose some corners of the original
image and there are some corners of the output
image which are unset.
So then we can combine shifting, scaling and
rotation all together into one overall transformation,
the input image to the output image. In order
to formalize this, we’re going to define
the coordinate of a pixel in the input image
using the notation U and V as we’ve done
all through this course. We’re going to
define the coordinate of the corresponding
point in the output image and I’m going
to denote those by U-prime and V-prime. So
we can write a very general function, U-prime,
as a function of the two input coordinates
and V-prime as a function of the two input
coordinates.
So in these two general functions fU and fV,
we can describe scaling, shifting, rotating,
various combinations of those and many other
kinds of very interesting distortions. You
can do funhouse mirror effects and so on.
Let’s look at a concrete example of scaling
and shifting, how we actually go about doing
that. We’re going to define a pixel in the
input image, coordinates U, V and it’s right
in the middle of the Mona Lisa’s eye. We’re
going to define the corresponding point in
the output image and its coordinates I U-prime
and V-prime. This output image is one quarter
the size of the input image and it’s offset
100 horizontally and 200 vertically. So we
can write a very simple relationship between
U-prime and U and between V-prime and V.
Now what we’re going to do is to consider
every pixel in the output image, every possible
value of U-prime and V-prime. For every value
of U-prime and V-prime that we look at in
the output image, we can compute what will
be the value of U and V in the input image.
So we look at every pixel in the output image
and we work out where it comes from in the
input image. So we have to in fact invert
those general equations that we wrote earlier,
the fU and the fV. Here we have inverted them
so that we’ve got U and V now in terms of
the output pixel coordinates, U-prime and
V-prime.
Let’s use an example to make this very tangible.
Let’s choose for example the output pixel
at coordinate 303 and 269. Given that, it’s
very easy to work out the coordinate of the
pixel in the input image.
Interestingly, the pixel in the input image
is fractional. We’re looking for the pixel
at 50.75 and 17.25 and this is a bit problematic
because pixels have got integer coordinates;
U and V that we’ve looked at so far have
always been integer values. So how do we go
about finding this fractional pixel value
in the input image?
Let’s consider that we’ve got a little
patch of the input image shown here in a very
zoomed-in fashion. So the particular pixel
that we’re looking for would actually lay
somewhere here in our grid of pixel values.
There are a few strategies that we can use
to determine the imaginary value of the pixel
at this particular coordinate shown here by
the yellow dot.
The first thing we can do is to take the value
of the pixel that’s closest, so the yellow
dot lies within the bounds of the pixel shown
here that’s got a value of 115. So we can
just say the pixel value is equal to 115.
But it’s in the bottom corner of that particular
pixel so you’d think that the 117 next door,
the 123 beneath it might actually elevate
the value there. A more sophisticated approach
then is to take a weighted average of the
neighboring pixel and the weights are proportional
to the distance between the pixel center and
the yellow dot marked here. This is the technique
that’s referred to as bilinear interpolation.
It can also be thought of as fitting a plane
to these four points. The pixel values represent
the height of the surface. We can fit a plane
to those four points and then we can determine
the height of that plane at the U, V coordinate
of the yellow dot.
Let’s consider now what happens if I choose
a pixel down here. So this output pixel, this
particular value of U-prime and V-prime, lays
outside the Mona Lisa image in the output
image. What’s going on here? If we take
this particular output pixel coordinate, 500,
300 and we map it to the coordinate in the
input image, we find that it lays way outside
the input image. So we can use some pretty
simple logic to say that an input image coordinate
like 1600, 400 lays outside the bounds of
the input image.
Therefore, we don’t have a value to put
into the output image at that particular point.
If this was a double-precision output image,
we might use the very special double-precision
value known as not a number or NaN to represent
pixels whose value we are unable to determine.
If it was an integer output image, we might
reserve a particular integer value, perhaps
zero, perhaps 255, to represent the pixels
whose value we are unable to determine.